this show is brought to you by helix
sleep
for a custom mattress
at the fraction of the cost go to helix
sleep dot com slash joey right now and
you're gonna get 50 off of your order
that's helix sleep.com
joey to get fifty dollars off of a
custom mattress made just for you that
you buy at helixsleep.com joey show is
also brought to you by onit.com go to
onyt.com and use codeword church to save
ten percent
on all their amazing optimization
products like alpha brain new mood
school tech immune and shroom tech sport
jesus
jesus [ __ ] christ
we're back [ __ ]
with one of the greatest songs of all
time
the church of what's happening now
sunday september 11th
respect
you don't want to know
are you [ __ ] kidding me
they'll never let you know
when you ask the reasons why
there we go
here we go [ __ ]
that's too deep turn that thing off
cut that [ __ ] thing that's too deep
i just saw myself playing basketball in
1977 and [ __ ] with skinny legs
what's going on lisa i never had skinny
legs it was [ __ ] up what's going on
don't worry about your [ __ ] legs
what's going on
what's going on um i had a good week i
went to with you to the show it's i love
going to comedy shows man it's uh
i was thinking about it today i've been
going to comedy shows i was one of the
nerds my mom
you're going to gotham in a couple weeks
my mom when i was
16 17 took my brother and i went to
gotham i there's something
even before i had i knew anything about
comedy or knew anything about going it
just
to me it blows
any anything out of the water sports you
can't really see if it's if it's a good
movie that's a maybe on par but a good
comedy show i [ __ ] love going
do you wait anticipate for laughter
or for the guy to [ __ ] die slow death
oh i've never wanted a guy to die a slow
i always go
anticipation laughter
yeah oh yeah like it's it got to a point
like uh
john panette a few years ago he passed
away a couple years ago
we my whole family and my like my
family's best friend family like my like
all the parents and stuff got along
we watched it we went on new year's eve
i must have been 15 16.
we went and saw john pinette as like a
family for new year's eve see i was more
of a music guy at that age like i liked
live entertainment
but i liked music and i liked
music at a big scale but then again i
liked music at a small scale like bands
would rehearse at my mom's bar when i
was a kid in the daytime
spanish man's whatever there was one
particular band that always rehearsed at
my mom's bar in the daytime in the back
from like 11 to 12 in the summertime
like six puerto rican kids in the
neighborhood
and i still remember one of their songs
but i liked
how they could just blend together
like that always [ __ ] with my head
like how do these guys blend together
yeah oh yeah [ __ ] kills me i just
want people to know you had to do 22
bunkers when i come to you off that's
why i don't have it at the house
tonight i'll have a hard time breathing
do you really have to the ball huh after
you smoke from a bong yeah for some
reason i get [ __ ] cooking i don't smoke
from a bung that much only two days a
week
it's uh
it's different i told you once you smoke
from a bong a lot
you [ __ ] uh i think my favorite's a
joint you haven't really been doing i
was thinking about that the other day
you haven't really been smoking joints
recently i'll tell you why i smoked a
joint at night
okay
i brought a big [ __ ] monster to put
me down
and like i said i've been talking about
it at times come for me to take a
breather i'm just killing myself to live
at this point in luggage
but you were talking about something
before we started the [ __ ] show about
reefer
that now you only work on reefer what
are you talking about it's weird like
when we first started and you always
make fun of me like there's a
i always used to like pass out and
sometimes sometimes i still do
but it's gotten to the point now where
for the past
what is it almost three years that i've
been doing this full time
i only work like people sometimes like i
read an article once like oh
employers now are letting more people
smoke a joint at lunch or something
because they say it helps productivity
or or whatever sometimes like oh i
remember getting drunk at like a
christmas party and now every time i
work
99 of the time
i'm like blasted beyond anyone else's
like conception of how like high they
can get a marriage to talk about this
last week you know you just become
adapt to the [ __ ] situation after a
while like
you have to force it that
if you're not high you feel [ __ ] up
like when i was shooting the longest
shot i was talking about a chicken and
she goes wait do you stop smoking
and that's when everything comes
into perspective you know
what do you mean
like when you stop smoking that's when
you like when i'm when i got locked up
that little time there i didn't smoke
up to that time i smoked to the minute
before i got sentenced
it was it was it's always been involved
in my life marijuana not for medical
reasons because i was a [ __ ] nut
but i went on a tail you know like i've
always said everybody raves about
colorado now i lived in colorado then
and the weed was still tremendous
compared to anywhere else i was getting
i wasn't traveling as much but when i
did travel i had the different spots i
went to
so
i smoked out of a bong that in colorado
90 of the people smoke out of a bung
they put snow in the bong ice cubes in
the bong or you know
so club soda with ice cubes it's it's
[ __ ] crazy
so that's where i got the lung thing
from all those years living in a high
altitude smoking a [ __ ] bong
i have terrible lungs i don't know what
it is oh no give me a [ __ ] month your
lungs will be [ __ ] so stretched out
you won't know what hit you let me tell
you what happened yesterday
guys
first off right now ebi is on
and i want to thank eddie bravo it's on
fight pass if you're a member of fight
pass
i'm going to watch it tonight when i get
home i feel [ __ ] very saddened that
i'm not there
i told eddie if we got out of here early
we would shoot over there
and uh that's it it's not that
i don't love eddie or i'm trying to bang
heads already or nothing like that i'm
leaving thursday i have a lot of things
to do tomorrow lee has a couple things
to do tomorrow
i'm busy as [ __ ]
and uh i just have to do the podcast
tonight i'd rather do it tonight so
people have it early monday morning so
bing bang boom your [ __ ] day starts
with some conversation here uh it's
really weird
lately i found myself in a predicament
that i haven't had since i was a
criminal what's that i'm busy
i'm busy
i cannot believe
what is on my plate
i really can't believe it and
when you look at it from the outside the
eye you're like okay you have those
three things on your plate no
it takes 35 minutes to get warmed up in
front of the computer to write these
things
and as you're writing you're getting new
ideas and you're writing those down and
you're writing and you're writing and
you're writing
so it's frustrating because guess what
at least i had i'm not a writer i'm
learning as i go
and so it there's a bigger learning
curve so like what do you say do you
want to break down the three things that
you're right like i'm trying to write
this book okay which
is great to write but painful at the
same time it's like bittersweet every
time i spit a line in there
i love it but it's like bittersweet
cause i'm i'm scratching a scab talk and
right now i'm in a real scabby [ __ ]
area let's just say
uh the special you know i listened to my
set friday night
and it was good
it wasn't what i wanted
not by any means but it's a style that i
like and i admire
if you do it a lot you'll bomb 90 of the
[ __ ] time i just got lucky that night
the right words came out of my mouth
saturday set was a little sloppier
and uh i came home a little frustrated
last night so last night like i
wrote some stuff out and i couldn't
believe that at one point it was 10 30
and the next minute was 1 30. damn you
know
and i put a [ __ ] 130 i was like what
you know just from scratching and
listening to the set from uh tuesday
night
at the [ __ ] uh dark horse and
you know a little set you talk for a
half hour you get one line
but to me that one line goes on the page
that i could refer back to and go jesus
that that's that made me giggle you know
what i'm saying like whatever
but for the first time in a long time
like
i'm telling you this i'm a good
organizer
that's one of my strong
peeps i could look at my day and go okay
this is how i have to chop it up you
know what this puzzle don't [ __ ] fit
here
and it's just gonna [ __ ] up my day let
me move this to win i'm one of those
guys i'm giving you enough window i know
about the 405.
i know about the one-on-one north at 2
30 or 11 30.
i'm busy right now right it's the
weirdest [ __ ] thing
i got myself into a little bit of a
[ __ ] pickle
and uh it's d d day's coming
and i know this and you have to keep a
podcast going you have to
there's so many things i'm one of those
people
that is raised
to
sit there
and while everybody else is giggling you
know i wasn't raised to take a vacation
uh you know
i questioned vacations a lot of people
agree or disagree with me
i'm the type of guy that i'm sitting and
i make a deal with myself and that's
great with the tv like today i watched
the giants and the cowboys i called you
while i was watching i wanted to see
what you were watching what was going on
with new england i didn't know new
england was playing tonight you know i
like football right
but i don't know all the movable players
you know what the best game in this
country is college football
really yeah if you really get to know
college football the top 10 you really
watch the purity of a game you really
learn on the period oh right okay
there's only one thing with college
football that the players move every two
or three years so every two or three
years you have to be involved that is
about these players
when you get drafted by the nfl you play
with the [ __ ] houston texans for 10
years of your career i get to know where
you are do you understand me i get to
know the team and the positions excuse
me but he had the older the more like i
used to watch sports and i haven't
turned on sportscenter any years so you
you uh
you know i revolved around sports and
something happened like in 1987 i
remember
it was the world series and i'm like
this is the first time
i'm not involved in the world series
and i think it was the twins were
playing the world series and i had to be
like
24 25 years old that was the first time
i got de-virginized from sports
that first [ __ ] world series
but to get back to this it's it's
very weird when you have a gun to your
head you know i have to
maintain my relationship at home
you know i have to be there in the
morning with her
i have to be there when she comes home i
need the dinners whether that's always
been important to me
but my work is also important to me you
know like what i do is important to me
uh let's be honest my social life
sucks dick
because uh the anti-social [ __ ] has come
up
by tremendous [ __ ] means you know
just come up just i don't know what it
is is it anti-social or i just think you
don't really like going if i go to a bar
if i go to a [ __ ] game right now and
this point in my life more than ever do
i think to myself what the [ __ ] i should
be doing something like today i was
watching the football game i watched it
for 30 minutes and i [ __ ] got up and
went and i wrote for [ __ ] an hour i
listened to the tapes i wrote i made
adjustments i scratched this that's [ __ ]
that i have to do
right you know this morning i got up
kind of late today i got up like at 8
30. okay which is late for me i got up
my wife boom boom we talked we hung out
i drank coffee with them i made a
protein shake for breakfast they left i
had 30 minutes of peace i sent a few
emails i made a few calls long distance
and bam i [ __ ]
put my little [ __ ] jiu jitsu suit on
and went over there and lifted i
stretched you know i put some blood in
my back
i said [ __ ] it i'll go in there and do
this and this and this and this and i
did it and i got up the [ __ ] because i
want to be ready for tomorrow i want to
be able to go tomorrow because with me
it's just numbers i'm not going to be
johnny [ __ ] tough
i'm going there just for the numbers
because i know the more reps i do the
better i'll get the more stamina and the
better you know the breathing and stuff
and you were talking about organizing
my issue with when i get busy
and you've talked with me about it
is
focus i focus way too far ahead i focus
on
what like a design for a name or i focus
on the name of a company rather than
focusing on working on like i always
daydreamer or fantasize about like how
fun it's going to be how how successful
it's going to be and then like i kind of
just skip
the actual work yeah part of it
which
55 of the people i've met out here
you know one in particular and i and i
saw it back then i saw it in 98
in 98 and my [ __ ] job jumping here
i would work telemarketing jobs just to
[ __ ] keep busy so i wasn't thinking
about comedy off [ __ ] day and i had a
steady check coming in beside the
goddamn 15 sets at the comedy store
and the 50 bucks i would get from willie
or jeff garcia or felipe or whatever to
do their little rooms and [ __ ]
i would work with different
telemarketing people and tell the
marketing people when when an account
dries up they go to different firms
so i was selling cigars but the company
i worked for
decided they were just going to open up
a cigar store and do the calls from
there they were going to change it all
around there was not going to be an
early morning shipped anymore
so i said i got to find something else
to sell so i went and sold
venture capital what is that when you
just invent invest money yeah let me see
venture capital venture capital people
because these people had this idea
of a tv show okay
but
the tv show was gonna get written by
this [ __ ] writer who had written on
this other tv show that was successful
on disney for 12 seasons blah blah blah
blah blah blah
these are the characters and this is
what the show's about
not only are we doing that and this is
when i saw it from an outsider's point
of view
they were also selling the merchandise
rights
to the shop so they were gonna have a
guitar a drums
posters lights right there i knew it was
a disaster
because you're not focusing they had one
page about the storyline
and 82 pages about the marketing that
we're gonna do for the [ __ ] uh
right there i learned that i learned it
right there like nobody taught it to me
i saw it
i saw how people
how far ahead of the game people get
yeah it's easy it's fun and uh no
it's not fun it's not fun when it comes
there's a difference like right now i'm
visualizing my special that's
that's one thing but i'm not visualizing
a madison square garden with [ __ ]
jay-z jumping up and down nobody'd be
like if you were visualizing the special
but not going out this month
right something like that like that's
that's what i get [ __ ] up with yeah no
no no but when you
want to sell those type of things
sometimes people get ahead of themselves
well think of that movie right
and right there right now
because you look worried about money
right there when you tell me that you're
gonna get this and get the movie rights
and think of all the hats we could sell
at the premiere
at 22.50 right there i know you have
nothing
and the people around you are
cheerleading that
so instead of worrying about like i told
you years ago a guy approached me by the
[ __ ] cop in new york
that loved martial arts so he wore
karate uniform everywhere kung fu suit
everywhere
the [ __ ] script lead was horrendously
bad everything about it was bad
but the main thing that pissed me off i
didn't mind going to the pitch was they
wanted me to walk in there with the
[ __ ] kung fu suit
they sent the tailor to my house i
refuse to let the [ __ ] guys like i
just
you don't want to wear the kimono or
whatever it's called [ __ ] no
why not
because i had to walk out of there with
the [ __ ] kimono on and i knew the
pitch was going to be terrifying they
were going to look at me and say well
thank you that's a great idea
let me think about it and i'll get back
to you guys now
with that failure i gotta walk out with
that [ __ ] suit on
and walk to my car like an [ __ ] and
see the valet that's why
last night i [ __ ] go out
and again for college uh football
reasons
the same reason why i don't watch that
many
i can't follow college football because
of all the movable [ __ ] parts
sometimes the ufc gets confusing oh yeah
you know five years ago the ufc wasn't
confusing
but now to me it's very confusing with
the ufc fight pass and
this fight is on here and this fight is
on there so i wait to see what's coming
on do i know all the fighters on the
card anymore lee
not really
not really you know i don't see brendon
vera i don't see all those you know
those are the guys phil davis
that i started watching the ufc with
they're all gone now there's north sage
cut there's all these [ __ ] kid jimmy
rivera i never i knew jimmy rivera had a
great shot against oh yeah he had a
great writer favor yeah i had read about
him a few weeks ago but i know believe
it or not
believe it or not late
i know nothing about the cm punk kid
and not till they did the documentary
about him that i even know what cm pun
looked like
i think he's very at least for me i
wasn't a a wrestling fan at all
they kept him very under wraps
until they started like i didn't even
get to see it they had like a six or
seven part documentary series on him
before the fight and but
as at least for me as the fight was
leading up the only thing i heard was
negative
like the only thing i heard was like it
was just weird
i didn't know anything about him i
didn't watch any of the documentaries
every time it was on
there was some type of comment on
twitter i couldn't punch he couldn't do
this he couldn't do that okay
so i i don't even look him up i don't
know nothing guys i have so much on my
[ __ ] plate
that sometimes i'm interested about
something but i don't even open the door
because i know i'm gonna read i'm gonna
have to get
it's like when you're reading a good
book you get intrigued by it and you
won't put it down and you have other
things to [ __ ] do
so that's why the computer is deadly oh
it is the computer is deadly when you're
trying to do something i just shut it
down
just close the [ __ ] thing because you
won't get nowhere because every eight
minutes your eyes stare over there
so
i get home last night again i'm i'm
bombing
and i want to listen to the tape and
listen to the one from friday and i'm
listening to all this [ __ ] last night
and at the same time you get bored after
12 minutes you put the earphones on and
you click
and i think i click on the yahoo page
and then torturing cw punk
see him cm punk whatever his [ __ ]
name is
i click to another page and it's endless
cm punk [ __ ]
tearing into and and and now i i get
intrigued i go how bad can the [ __ ]
be i'm not gonna get the fight to watch
it
i just wait till some [ __ ] dude
post the link posted on it and sure
enough ten seconds after i said that
bing
a link comes up with the [ __ ] fight
and he looks horrendously bad
and i look at him lee on the floor
and uh i click it out and i leave the
room for some reason to smoke a joy or
something i come back
i open up the computer again i get my
notebook out and there again
is more cw
whatever his [ __ ] name is punk
and i
for one minute there i go jesus christ
cmcw punk
doesn't matter
in your life
this much
like there was just so much hatred
about this guy
and at the end of the day the way i
looked at it was from what i heard he
gave up wrestling
what do you mean what did he give up
wrestling like whatever oh yeah yeah
he's not fine he's not wrestling was he
rich like was he he was from what i've
heard from like steve simone and he was
like one of the top in the wwe and i
think don't quote me on this there might
have been like a contract dispute or
something to that sort and then at that
point like he was he was going to come
back maybe not come back and then that
was two years ago when he joined the ufc
okay so he went
he started training somewhere at duke
rufus yeah
which is a hard academy and you'll learn
a lot it's a lot to get absorbed
and they got the guy ufc fight now
in my world you know what man
he was [ __ ] delusional
you know he was a little bit on the
delusional side
uh
i know
just as a [ __ ] comedian that you're
gonna fight
you have to be doing it for a while oh
yeah and you have to have a couple of
fights in the competition level
then a couple fights you know it just
takes a couple things things that the
record's never going to come up
you know what i'm saying like it's never
going to come up you went to a
competition one time
and you when you go to those
competitions the regular karate ones you
fight like three times
you know you fight like three three
minute round to something until the
winner gets decided
it's not full contact
but just that semi-contact lee
teaches you how to move your hands what
to block for those karate kicks are
slick they fake to your [ __ ] stomach
and they pop up to your [ __ ] face you
can't touch the face but you can touch
the body and from there
you move on to a few jiu jitsu
tournaments
and then from there you do a couple mma
things right this would be what i think
would be the obvious [ __ ] pattern
this is what i'm just assuming yeah okay
and after you have
after you go eight no and the mma
lower division you know fight fights in
tarzana on saturday night in the back of
the church that type of [ __ ] you get 52
dollars and your trainer gets 11
after eight of those you send a tape to
joe avila whatever his [ __ ] name is
the guy who got fired from the ufc
and they decide yes or no or they hear
about you in the lo something
you know
so when i didn't see for me in my world
i really didn't know
in my world it could have been that cm
punk was a wrestler but maybe in high
school he boxed
maybe in college he [ __ ] uh did
something was it ncaa champion wrestler
i didn't know what the [ __ ]
particulars were
but then i find out this guy's got no
credentials whatsoever
that's what you're trying to tell me
like no credentials he went from
professional wrestling
right into this [ __ ] thing that's
what yes okay and then he goes in the
ring and he gets [ __ ] demolished
right yeah and and to be honest you
asked earlier and anything you heard
about him i forgot about maybe three to
six months ago there were articles going
around that i read that he had lost like
15 out of 16 fights that they had
brought in for him in the gym like
secret fights
so that that that's when i heard like
the negativity first started for that i
started hearing because i don't really
go on boards and obviously i'm not in
the world so i don't know anything but
that like i heard he lost 15 out of 16
like
pre-fights because i was wondering why
they didn't do that with him and they
probably just can't because he's so
famous and popular people would go for
his knees or maybe they don't want
people to see him losing or who knows
you know
you know man oh absolutely
at the end
cm punk raised his hand
and they agreed
to let him fight
now in my world where i'm coming from i
think it's a business move correct yeah
probably something it's a business move
because there's no way lisa wakes up
tomorrow morning
at eight o'clock in the morning and he
calls me he goes hey [ __ ] this
week i'm calling you but i got bad news
i'm quitting
i'm going over the six and
kickboxing at ten o'clock
i'm gonna start kickboxing
and then at two o'clock i'm going to see
justin fortune and i'm going to be
coming i'm a mma fighter and i'm going
to the 6 30 jiu jitsu class in alberto
ukraine and i'll be sitting there going
late what the [ __ ] are you talking about
and all of a sudden a year from now you
call me up and you go hey what are you
doing friday night can you come and
corner me
one of you you know yeah i want to box
this dude up in [ __ ] tarzana
you know
that that's the evolution lee but if you
come to me
tomorrow and go in two years i'm gonna
have my first fight i don't know where
they're going to give it to you but
let's pretend you call rogan rogan goes
yeah i'll talk to dana
and we'll put you in the [ __ ] ufc
it's not that simple it was because you
showed up with an envelope and the ufc
knew and they took a chance well to me
it seems the only i'm not even aside
from cm punk it seems like the ufc and
the wwe must be doing some sort of deal
because they're using cm punk which the
wwe must own some part of
the name you can't call yourself your
wrestling name in the ufc which is kind
of weird
but
it's it's
a lot of people are saying it's unfair
and i guess it is but at some point you
have to understand like you said the ufc
is a business so there's no this isn't
like a state run you've like a fight
league this is a business who can do
whatever they want
and
but like the one thing i got from from
him and i just i just feel terrible he
just seems so lonely like whenever when
i was watching that like the un
embedded or whatever he was just in his
house like he's getting all this hate
online and
i personally i felt like his speech at
the end was a little bit corny like it
just seemed a little bit out of place at
the ufc
but it had a nice message and i just
felt like i feel like he's a nice guy
and he's just getting just [ __ ] on like
constantly you know i i sat there last
night here i am a little on the stone
side
and i'm sitting and i'm thinking to
myself well
you know what man
at the end of the day
would joe diaz have done it
[ __ ] you yeah
[ __ ] you i would have had an anxiety
attack walking to that octagon
that my head would have blown up
even if i would have trained for two
years even if i lost 15
out of six or whatever the [ __ ] it was i
would have the anxiety that i would die
i would die
i could have dealt with the 15 in the
[ __ ] octagon i would have lost the
first three
and then at least the next three fights
i could throw a punch i would have got a
[ __ ] a sweep
i would have got a hip escape you know
back to my guard i could do those simple
[ __ ] things but i wasn't gonna and
then maybe the
the the ninth fight
i knocked them down and i got on top and
the time right now
you know so i did a little [ __ ] well
you know i don't i wouldn't have been
ready for the ufc i would have [ __ ]
had a nervous breakdown so in my mind
all i wanted to say on twitter was
i didn't know who he was you know he
looked like a [ __ ] dork to me every
time i saw him
i mean it's not like he came in looking
like brock lesnar or yoked and [ __ ] no
you know you could see the steroids wore
off
you know you can see that it doesn't
take a [ __ ] genius
and uh he went in there he got beat up
like that people like you can look like
an [ __ ] in front of 11 million people
i gotta tell you something
to me
he looked like a guy with balls
i wouldn't have done that hell no i
wouldn't have done it either
but
i just i don't like how people say he
was delusional
he he raised his hand maybe he was
delusional but somebody should have said
sit on the um let me talk to you about
something
listen things are bad those guys hit
really [ __ ] hard you were in
professional wrestling they don't do
dick in there like what they do in the
ufc they body slam you those punches to
the [ __ ] head right you'll hear rings
later on you'll think that somebody
grabbed you by the head and they tapped
that's how [ __ ] hard those punches
are to your [ __ ] head
i think but nobody did that they said
you want to fight
it's a good idea we'll get you a fight
train for two years and let them know
when you're ready
it's not the guy's fault man
it's like a fight tomorrow call madison
square garden and go you know what i'm
ready to [ __ ] sell master grey garden
[ __ ] hold on jerry let's look at the
computer
they'll come back and go are you [ __ ]
crazy
but if i get some weird lady and she's
like
we can make money somewhere
there's some way we can make money with
this
or we could build this up to be an event
or something like that it just didn't
get built up or anything like that so
it backfired the whole way through i
feel bad for the guy i would feel really
bad if they didn't give him another
fight
i hope they just give him an e like uh
like it's something not easy but just
like give him something so what make it
just does he fight that uh let me check
i think it's 170 but
i like just permitting another promotion
or something for a little bit
that's right
how old is he sam punk he's old well not
really but he's like mid-thirties
probably let me check
it just to me i i see sometimes i i
think it's balls
and i applaud the guy whether i like his
beliefs and i don't even know anything
about him i'm just saying like that's
what i thought of last night when i was
stoned to the [ __ ] gills
that this guy had balls that's it
and somebody took it else as a business
venture this guy [ __ ] balls boom
that's it people got pissed off at me on
twitter i woke up this morning with two
thousand angry [ __ ] tweets like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
matt matrion got involved john fit i'm
like guys all i said was that [ __ ] at
the end of the day
i got to give the guy some credit i
don't care if he got embarrassed in
front of 11 million people
sometimes you're getting back got to get
back some defense he didn't just get
destroyed it wasn't like he got knocked
out in three seconds he defended a
little bit and he's 37 and he's a
middleweight yeah that's tough age
well god bless him man
the internet has just become
a weird thing i have a lot of good times
on the internet
but i see a lot of dumb [ __ ] on the
internet and i gotta be honest with you
i see seventy percent dumb [ __ ]
and thirty percent of [ __ ] that matters
not even thirty for me i don't think
or at least 30 that like on social media
is that what you mean well
you know like i told you i
leave
lincoln then don't stop
they don't stop
they're not gonna stop i don't know what
i'm gonna do
i've never signed a contract nothing to
be with lincoln then they keep saying
someone wants to email him listen i have
i love my twitter
i really do i have fun on my twitter i
can't be on it all day no i love my
facebook because i have two sets of
completely different friends on my
facebook
you know i don't take pictures
so i don't like to [ __ ] instagram
that much taking pictures of me and
lunch and [ __ ] like that
i don't know what else is out there you
know people keep hitting me up with
snapchat i'm good with periscope for
right now it's all videos you don't need
to stop yeah i don't know anything about
this stuff so
the more you let enter your life
the more it takes away from your life
so the more internet things you're
playing on you know i go to my fitness
pal
which takes a couple minutes they're
[ __ ] up
and i go to
jiu jitsu journal.com
i write what i learned how i did if i
rolled or not how many times i got the
[ __ ] knocked out of me
i read all that stuff in there
but besides that i don't go anything for
entertainment
if something happens and i see it on the
news or something or they talk about it
on the news or as i'm walking by
i will go on yahoo news locally or
nationwide and read what the [ __ ]
going on
but besides that i'll let myself get
caught up in anything i don't like i
don't know what an app is
i don't know how to work a [ __ ] app
none of that [ __ ]
it's uh
it's a it's a huge time suck and i think
that's where a lot of people my age are
getting stuck in the
like the daydreaming part because they
go on facebook and they put up a post
like i
though there's a thing now on facebook
like on this day and i hate it because i
was a douche bag like not even i wasn't
mean
but i'm just looking at my statuses and
i'm like god no wonder i didn't have any
friends like they're just terrible
and it's just like you're like oh
i'm not letting anything get to me
anymore and all that baloney that's on
there and i i just think it's
i think and it's you know what's crazy
i'm i started looking into some facebook
ads for some people
they can literally they can send ads to
you
if you're in a relationship if you're in
a if you've just gotten a new job if you
just moved
if you if you just broke up they can
send ads to you based on everything
everything that you're putting on there
they can send ads do you want now
so so the computer knows what type of
stuff you're putting on your page
facebook knows yeah facebook knows and
they attack that they they have the
ability to yeah so that means everyone
is yes
so that's that's why people who have
been in relationships for a while
probably getting like like i i get uh
engagement ring ads now
i've been in a relationship with paulo
for over three years
so and they know it
and i i stupidly oh i want to get the
likes on the on in a relationship so now
they know i'm sure you'll get
do you get you might want to look next
time your anniversary with your wife
comes up see if you get like anniversary
reminders
i don't think i put it on there oh it's
on there okay no no no i gave him as
limited information as i could to get
the [ __ ] on there yeah let's look at the
looks of the house you just said
something to me before
you thought i smoked in the house
i i didn't know you smoked i didn't
think
i i
i can smell it a little bit when i go in
there
and then i just know you have
access to the outside pretty close to
your what do you smell in the office
just when i walk in i can just smell
that i don't think anyone's smoked in
there but i think i can just smell it
it's there oh no no it's a fireplace oh
okay so it smells like smoke oh okay
then
yeah it scares the [ __ ] out you think
something's burning
lee i gotta tell you something
and i want to talk to some people about
this i
used to smoke in the house till my wife
got pregnant
and i'm old schooly i don't give a [ __ ]
when i got a license a nut
i smoke reefer if i got it
if i'm at your house watching a movie
i'm lighting up a [ __ ] joint
that's it that's kind of like going out
to the balcony
you know there was no being
cautious when i was growing up that was
there just wasn't so it didn't stick
with me
as i got older i realized yeah i got a
smoke on the balcony
when i go to a hotel i don't spark in
the [ __ ] room that's like inviting
help on the road because it's right in
your room and you get charged or you're
throwing they charge the room 250
and if somebody complains that security
knocks at your [ __ ] door like in the
nice hotels
and you don't need that in your [ __ ]
life what if they throw you out what if
they decide to call a [ __ ] cop i'm
sitting there with
three more [ __ ] joints or
a lollipop or something that's control
over
whatever
yeah so you know what i take the joint i
bring my
ipod and i go for a walk around the
[ __ ] city
and i smoke a [ __ ] joint right out in
the open i go to like a little park
where they have a memorial for
some [ __ ]
old man soldier from 19 [ __ ] uh 10
like on a horse or something with a hat
and i'll make believe i'm reading it and
i'll just take a little [ __ ]
you know where there's going to be a cop
or something no i'll look around if
there's a cop there's a car right not
necessarily yeah but usually how many
[ __ ] cops do you see on a beat
anymore
unless you're watching a movie from new
york you don't see cops on the beat not
in that lane up here i would be nervous
i'm like a cop no dude
when i was a larry me and larry
walked to las vegas boulevard and stat
under the [ __ ] elevator smoked right
there oh god and you know people pulling
us to us in the cars
asking us what we were doing and [ __ ]
anyway answer
just sitting out here
really what are you doing you're smoking
no because i had the joint cup in my
[ __ ] hand
but just because i'm a [ __ ] i love to
smoke
i have never since my wife told me she
was pregnant
have i ever even considered smoking that
[ __ ] house
i wouldn't just because the way i was
raised
and looking back i didn't like it
i didn't like it you know what there's
always my mom respected me in other ways
but that was one way that i didn't like
it
yeah when i was a kid i smelled
marijuana i didn't like it i should have
never smelt that [ __ ]
because once you smell it out once you
smell it in your house then you smell it
out then your head blows up because
people like that's marijuana have you
smoked that before and you gotta lie no
not really
meanwhile you're thinking your mom
smokes [ __ ] reefer and her friend
smokes reefer and this is why they go
out on the balcony and this is why you
found rolling papers it really wasn't
[ __ ] louise to
tobacco
so
that's how i found that i put two and
two together and then i knew what that
[ __ ] smell was then
yeah my godfather smoked around me told
me not to say nothing
am i mad it's weird i'm not mad at my
godfather
for smoking pot around me but i'm mad at
my mother for smoking pot in the house
why
you know whenever i smoked with gabby we
smoked in the car
and we smoked after chinese food
i didn't say we smoked i'm sorry he
smoked i was a young little boy
but my mother smoked in the [ __ ]
house
and looking back on it you're
disrespecting the [ __ ] house
just what the whole family thing you
know what i'm saying i don't know you
know i'm weird about this [ __ ]
so that's why i don't want to do it in
front of mercy in the house i don't want
to smell it
i have my pipe head in the yard my
lighter she can't find it even if she
[ __ ] wanted to i hide it right in the
[ __ ] barbecue thing
okay well you pick it up
oh so let's hit it the weeds hitting
everything's [ __ ] weird hidden at all
times
i don't want to find it i don't want to
ask me i don't want to [ __ ] smell it
there's going to be a time she's going
to smell it and then we'll break it down
have you thought about what you're going
to say not really not really because who
the [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] it'll probably be
10 years from now she'll smell it like
three or four years and ask
then she'll put it together she'll read
about it they'll come with her in school
with the damn project
by that time i'm gonna have to be going
for walks and have cologne on my neck
and change my shirt and [ __ ] like that
because their senses are so [ __ ]
unbelievable she'll ask me why does your
shirt smell like smoke
people people who don't smoke
really [ __ ] smell oh yeah it sticks
out they really [ __ ] smell it at this
point it's in my pores it's in my jeans
it's in my [ __ ] t-shirts
it's in my keys it's in my bags when i
grab the bags i could smell the [ __ ]
weed
you i have an essence of brief around me
that's what i think i'm smelling in your
office
yeah i i have an essence of reef around
me
it's in my clothes i could smell it
sometimes i go on you know when i smell
it when i go on the road
and i didn't put weed in the bag but
there's still
that smell of it in my [ __ ] clothes
all those clothes have been washed
with with detergent
fabric softener you know the whole
[ __ ] thing the towel and the [ __ ]
dryer they've just been fumigated with
weed smoke for so long
no it just goes into your pores and i
think there's nothing really you could
[ __ ] do about it
once it goes into your pores and you
sweat it out there and it's not like i
think from us eating it i think it also
has to do with the cbd oil i'm using now
okay it has to do with now i'm putting
it in my system at a lot of different
levels so
oh yeah how's the cbd oil going
i'm so sorry i'm very sorry about that
i'm gonna be honest with you people at
home
i've been doing the cbd all since uh we
had the guests hawaiian chris on the
show
and i'm gonna tell you what i've
experienced
do i still have [ __ ] pains
yes but i'm also a 300 pound man going
to jiu jitsu
and wrestling with young kids and
sometimes i rush up and get the bottom
line is this i used to have this chronic
chronic knee pain
it's pretty much
the pain is lowered to the minimum
if i twist my leg a little bit it's
lowered to the middle
so like maybe from like a one to a one
on a scale one to ten
i went from i went from an eight to a
two damn
the pain in my wrist
i still have it but the flexibility and
the mobility is unbelievable i hurt my
wrist
for you people you can't see it it's
[ __ ] brown right now
rightly what color do you see it like
half your red and it was like only a
little bit
my first one yeah
this was an armbar that got caught maybe
three weeks ago oh my god and then it
hurt my wrist and uh
hey what are you gonna do it doesn't
hurt now
i keep putting ice on it if i go to the
doctor anyway tuesday at 8 30 in the
morning so
if i could stay alive till then we're
good i love that your doctor was on the
show at the show on friday and he was
like dog am i okay that's my cuban
doctor i don't think he's a doctor
anymore
i met him about 15 [ __ ] years ago at
the comedy store
and we became friends
but he had a quality that i knew
he couldn't be a good doctor what was
that he always had a different woman but
that seemed like a good thing if i see
him on friday and saturday he had two
different women [ __ ]
and he was doing powder and he was
jumping up and down and you know a
doctor
remember i had the doctor at doctors
and i saw his decline
i saw his decline a man that i loved
very much he wasn't only my doctor but i
loved him very much i got it
jesus my [ __ ] proton
thank you he was my doctor so i became
friends with him then he became my you
know even when my mom was alive he knew
things that my mom he wouldn't tell my
mom okay you can find it in them
yeah i can find them and you know
thank you lee look at lee's [ __ ]
producing tonight turning off
microphones and [ __ ] but i can fire them
and then i [ __ ] it up
because i stepped over the line i went
over there
and tried to get uh
i traded them cocaine for steroids
[ __ ]
you're you're from the doctor you had as
a family
[ __ ] doctor after my mom died i kept
in touch with him and i would go over
and get prescriptions from time to time
you know from my throat and [ __ ] he
wouldn't charge me he'd call the [ __ ]
pharmacy for me
and then uh
in 82
everybody was shooting uh
liquid steroids
the ones that you shoot with a needle
into your arm and stuff
and i had a friend one day that was a
dear friend of mine and we were talking
one day and he spoke about he wanted all
the steroids
if i could get him and i thought i
banged my head everywhere i couldn't get
him and one day i go you know what i
gotta go down there anyway let me ask
him
and one day i went down there the guy
gave me like a half a physical he
wouldn't take blood out he knew i didn't
like needles and [ __ ]
and uh i just asked him
i said what can you get me and he goes
what do you want to do and i told him
and he gave me a prescription winstrol v
okay and would he be oral
and i would take him to the pharmacy
and i would sell them to my friend
that's [ __ ] like
that's not like i'm surprised you're so
like
so so bad like that's [ __ ] up but you
knew him since you were i could and then
i got to the point where i was going
over there twice a month
to pick up a prescription for winnie v
or anavar okay
and
the boat did just mild steroids okay and
he'd ship him over to a pharmacy
and i'd go to the pharmacy is whatever
and i'd [ __ ] take them and i'd sell
them to my buddy
just like that
that's a lot to do man no what's there
to do it's even it's [ __ ] up it seems
like i see it's controlled a lot more
now
back then it wasn't as controlled as it
was now they weren't looking for
steroids mild steroids
and anavar and winnie v
are mild steroids they're usually given
to people after surgery after a burn
stuff like that because it builds up the
skin you know
i think what it is
is like when you when you say these kind
of things
i think like i think back to my family
doctor
and like
until the time i was 18 or something
probably until the time i even left it
for college
like she had like the little pictures up
on the wall and you got stickers as you
left and
i can't imagine going to them
six years later and trying to
get a prescription for steroids
it's like it's just so far out of my
realm late
since my how
far my memory goes back
he was my doctor [ __ ]
he was my doctor all the way when i
lived on
29th street but i don't remember the
drama until 205 west 88th street the
drama with needles with needles that's
when he would come over with the long
you know like the jackets the rain
jackets
and he would have the little bag with
him and that's [ __ ] he would talk to
my mother and the babysitter and then i
was able to walk in the room and take my
temperature
and then he'd say okito i gotta give you
a needle and i go no no and he'd go look
at your throat and he'd work through the
steps of me he was a great guy that's
why i loved him
because he would get the mirror and show
me my throat then get the stick and then
take the [ __ ] things and put him on
my own heart he was a great doctor right
he tried everything he'd do to relax me
and then he [ __ ] you know try to con
me he'd go all right what do you want to
do
you wanted your armor and your leg and i
go i don't want it anywhere he goes we
just had to talk
you were just going to let me do it
and i go no let me think about it he go
okay
and he'd go out of the room
and my mom would offer him if he was
hungry or if he wanted a beer and he
would start [ __ ] drinking
and he would do like three [ __ ]
cocktails
and then he'd come back and then he goes
so what are we deciding i don't know
give me 10 more minutes
and then he go out there and do like a
blast to coke with my mom or the
babysitter whatever was in the living
room then they come back all cooked up
and him and my mom would come in like
what the [ __ ] you're ready my mom would
come and yell let's do this [ __ ]
and i go no let me think about it i'm
almost ready and he would go out and do
another blast then he'd come in and
[ __ ]
give me the shot
my ass would be purple
because i tighten up
i tightened up in those days
so my leg would get tight to resist the
needle
needles would [ __ ] go in there and
then my whole cheat ass cheek would get
purple it was horrifically horrific
when i used to go to the doctor my mom
would take us for ice cream after
this guy wouldn't give me no lollipop
but not he just talked to me about life
and girls and cars and movies he was
that type of doctor he was a hip [ __ ]
doctor man
and i knew he was always kinky i just
didn't know what he did
you know i found out what he did
when i got off on coke the first time
i thought about him
what do you mean you need an off on coke
because i did coke for a year when i was
a kid and nothing ever happened okay i
want to get okay and one day i drank
alcohol and the coke hit me oh it became
something else and then after that the
coke started hitting me every time i
drink alcohol okay
sorry
um
so then what happened when when when he
went off for a year
when you got all four four years you
said you got off coke for a year and you
thought of them
i thought of dr dovale yeah because
i realized the reason why his jaw would
move
uh
whenever he would come into the room his
jaw would move that's a basic cocaine
signal like when you have a thousand
friends who their [ __ ] jaws go for
hours
whenever his jaws went and then one day
i put it together i got high and i'm
like oh [ __ ]
so all those years dovale was doing
[ __ ] coke
so i didn't hit him up until that time
remember i got really sick
when i was 16 the summer of 79 i got
really [ __ ] sick i got a lung
infection
and i got i got a lung doctor
brought in to specialize and stick the
scope down my throat and scrape my lung
and see what was on there
before they scraped my lung i called the
valley and told them to come to the
hospital
like listen to something i gotta tell
you you gotta get in that [ __ ]
emergency room or wherever the [ __ ] it
is
when they scrape my lung
you gotta hide the results from my mom
he's like what are you talking about
and i'm like listen i did crystal thc
and he goes what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like i did some [ __ ] that
you snort
and he goes you know that's angel that's
that's the first person that ever told
me that was angel plus i was like a
[ __ ] naive kid
at 16 doing jesus christ that summer we
were doing a lot of it like that six
months prior to it
so it was gonna be all over my lungs
and he goes listen i'll tell you what
i'm gonna do i'll look at the report
and if
it's on there i figure out how to get it
off but i want you to make me a promise
don't do that [ __ ] no more
and i looked at him like oh you
i think you do you know like we had and
he told me to my at that time i hadn't
done
coke i always knew he was up to
something i just didn't know what you
know
okay
but once i got high like a year later i
put two and two together and i go that's
what this [ __ ] was doing
so now i'm gonna break his ball i never
broke his balls about it to be honestly
but the first time i asked him for the
steroid prescription
he goes take the prescription but the
next time you come here you better bring
me a present and better may not be
aspirin
[ __ ] so i would show up dango let me get
another prescription here i brought you
some
and just those
three or four bumps he'd do i would
never do the coke in front of them i had
known them that long
so at that time those people did not
know i was doing coke okay i just told
them that i had friends who did it and
they got really good coke and this was a
present for him for helping him out
i told him that the kid he was giving
the steroids to
was sending him coke oh
so how how would you make money what do
you make money on the deal yeah i go
into the city and i get an eight ball of
coke
right for like 250 or [ __ ] eight and
then i throw a gram on it
and i get four and a half grams so now
what did i pay 250
right right and how many grams i got
four so what's that divided into 250
60 yeah 60 bucks 62.50 yeah yeah 62.50
so in those days cocaine cost 100
[ __ ] bucks okay all right so i would
take the [ __ ] cocaine
and bring it to him he'd do it lose his
[ __ ] mind
he'd give me the prescription
the prescription would cost me six
dollars
i would take it to my friend he'd give
me 200.
so it would cost me [ __ ] 75 and i'd
make 125 profit
that's not bad
that's a lot of work though
no it wasn't no work at all well it's
dangerous it's like it's not what lee
are you [ __ ] crazy what do you mean
chris what danger what danger is there
what where is do you encounter the
danger buying coke
transporting coke not really what were
you just you just met me two days ago
you what did you become a [ __ ] uh
magenta you watched narcos i know you
didn't get caught this is good
this was when
you looked so much the part you lived so
much the part
that it was like you felt invisible
it was like you felt invisible
timmy holloway is listening to this
right now and next time i have a
conversation he'll tell me about
i used to go into the city and it was
like i didn't matter
sometimes i had 200 on me
sometimes i had 700 army
sometimes had 1200 on me and i look you
as a face as a man
i was never worried one time
never worried one time
coming back over that tunnel i always
knew that if you went over the tunnel
don't come back over the tunnel come
back over the bridge
that's math 10 [ __ ] one
that's math 101
if you take the bus over the [ __ ]
tunnel
you take the train uptown and you take
the [ __ ] bus over the lincoln tunnel
now over the bridge vice versa also
you make something out of it so they
don't pinch you as a [ __ ] whatever
you always have an excuse for why you
went there
but what if the cops just having a bad
day and it's like hey you
no cop's having a bad day like that
really no cop you have a daily news
under your arm you have a you
you have a jean jacket it looks like you
[ __ ] belong there and you're just
walking down the street inside the jean
jacket there's a flat pocket if you have
a lee legion jacket or wrangler and you
could tuck your [ __ ] 12 or 15 14
grams all the way down to the bottom
and nobody knows nothing
it would be the biggest thriller of your
life you're walking down now you got to
make sure that you don't go into nowhere
weird
what are you saying joey don't stop at a
[ __ ] porno hub
because they got people that you never
know you take your jacket off
the chicks giving you a lap dance and
next thing you know she's clipping you
12 grams of
coke so you go from point a
to point b
a lot of things can happen when you have
that blow in your pocket that's the
danger
exactly that's what i'm scared of no
there's nothing's gonna happen the worst
thing you and i are gonna do with two
fat flux we're gonna stop at raised
pizza and get a slice of pizza in the
soda
that's it
if i had that on me i wouldn't stop
anywhere and maybe we won't stop
maybe we won't something we'll just
shoot right down we got to stop and get
a hot dog
we had because we had to go over there
for something
we had to go over there for something
so we're not lying
can't do that first
no
yeah it depends if we if you and i come
up the tunnel
yeah i could stop at the [ __ ] some
pizza on 88th street and shoot up get
the [ __ ] two eight balls and shoot
over the [ __ ] thing yeah i'm not
stopping in the pizza no me i could look
in the face and tell you that one time
was i scared bringing that cup over the
time
all right now you go home you cut it you
sell a little bit of it
you get a ride from a friend of yours
from 78th street down to 36 in west new
york uh down to 36 and uh
where the [ __ ] was his office 36 it was
on that last street between weehawken
and no water
and it was right down there park avenue
you went down to park avenue when you're
in the city you got you went into the
office there was no receptionist
it was just him
he was the whole show
he had [ __ ] all the receptionists he
knocked them up god knows what could
have happened with orlando
you went in you gave him the package
that was it that was the last of the
transaction you did
he called the pharmacy
so i got back in my buddy's car and he
gave me a ride by the time i get to the
pharmacy the prescription is ready
in my head i'm like okay what if i got
an idea in my pocket with my name on it
and i take the prescription with my name
on it that's it it's all legal
the guy i send it to
i grew up with the [ __ ] guy
it's pills i know for a fact he does
blow i know for a fact that he's got two
kilos at the house or maybe an ounce or
maybe a gram
doesn't matter to me
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to take those pills out of that
container
and put them in a different container
and light that [ __ ] container on fire
like if it was a [ __ ] numbers
paperwork why
now the felony is that they catch him
with that container with your name on it
oh so just brought in the container
burn the [ __ ] container
and give them a different [ __ ]
container
where's the damage like
there's no damage where's tony bennett
put that [ __ ] on
okay
we used to do
with lee
all right cut that right there lee i
want you to find frank sinatra i want to
be around
okay i'm gonna teach you a little lesson
and [ __ ] why don't we eat a couple more
a couple more
we're getting the party started lee it's
[ __ ] monday september 11th
and we're celebrating by uh doing a
special podcast right
you know out of respect that's the least
we could do i don't want to come out
here and have a wine fest or whatever
all i want to do is let them know i
acknowledge them his ego
there you go
who should you make me these are great
all these need is whipped cream
this is the best flavor i've ever tasted
in my life you know why cause there's no
weed in it
there's like [ __ ] no milligrams of it
yeah but that chocolate from chibichu is
very good it is i just saw you go like
this
like two times
listen to frank sinatra's version
oh
bam we got two more bags of stars here
this turned into a good [ __ ] party
tonight see
i mean you and i always get creative oh
yeah
and if i look i noticed they had acid
somewhere in this [ __ ] office you
understand me
that's how not
thanksgiving you like me lee cox sucker
nobody
right now you'll be at home with paula
somewhere rubbing your feet watching bad
tv
this is james brown
this is amazing
three completely different well sinatra
and whatever cruisers
that's [ __ ] amazing
a black dude that's tremendous and too
cruel is singing the same [ __ ] song
with three two different twists on it
this is the [ __ ] that makes my dick hard
because
it just goes to show you you could
[ __ ] cook spaghetti 50 different ways
you know i'm saying
i feel like paula made me spaghetti
carbonara
which what was it
it's like the one with a little bit of a
bacon in it and then a little bit of
just butter and egg and she just like
with an egg yolk yeah or the whole egg
uh i don't know if she made it and then
you put parmesan cheese on them
the [ __ ] yeah i used to eat that all the
time she made it for me she made it for
me she learned how to make it in italy
it was [ __ ] great
look at she brought back recipes from
italy
she couldn't bring you back a [ __ ]
salad
it's gotta be pasta with an egg butter
more butter no but we didn't she's
yelling me but what like we only have
one bowl we didn't get crazy you spray
butter no no no god's sake i know you
spray butter when you're getting worse
and worse with this [ __ ] actually she
wouldn't she made it she wouldn't use
spray butter she thinks the same way
good does she take and throw in the
garbage nah she doesn't go to that level
yet well that's don't ever have me over
yeah it's the first time you go to the
bathroom
i'll throw that [ __ ] thing out i
wanted a tab when i was a kid i started
throwing away people's ashtrays
why because i hated them
i hated ashtray so when people weren't
looking i threw their [ __ ] ashtrays
away
why didn't you like ashtray my friend
george
i threw all his ashtrays away when he
looked at me in boulder oh
and what did he say
i'd ask him he was crazy
i don't know what the [ __ ] you talking
about why would i take your ass travel
smoke pot
i only smoke pot i smoke it outside
you wouldn't know i love [ __ ] with
people sometimes you gotta take the
ashtray sometimes you always ask me
about drugs late at night
like one night lee called and we had a
two-hour conversation
about a drug network
like leah was asking me about my friend
who sells coke
but i was telling lee that i've known
these guys in hollywood
that i've been selling i've known them
since 97 i met them
through a white jewish dude named white
lightning
and white lightning used to sell weed
used to date a black chick
that used to [ __ ] the same a coke dealer
and he didn't know it
he thought they were just friends he was
[ __ ]
and she had a kid
and he was happy she was half jamaican
and he was this jewish dude that you
could just take money from him
at the time josh wolfe and i josh wolf
had an apartment in this building
and he would be very paranoid about
hiding his weed his apartment
so he would hide in the parking garage
and we would steal it once a month
then when he caught on he started hiding
in some girl's apartment he'd have three
four pounds at a time
because that's what he does he's a
promoter slash weed dealer
so if you want to buy the good weed you
got to go to the parties and pay 20 to
get in and buy his [ __ ] wheat it was
a great scam he had going on
what was i talking about
stealing joshua swede so uh
no we're talking about a drug thing oh
uh yeah the people who you met
the do your drug dealer in hollywood so
i met this kid and uh
i went over there a few times the coke
was good you know at this time i didn't
want to go to the store and buy it all
the time you know when you're a [ __ ]
junkie you got to have a different
couple different outlets and nobody
catches on to what you're doing
so i had our compadre
i had i had uh the comedy store
and i met this guy and he goes he get
good coke so he introduced me to this
kid and i would go over there was
walking distance from my house
which was perfect in hollywood and i
would walk over there
and buy coke from him it was him and a
white dude at the time
and i would go over and say hello and
they were playing those games
they were playing those stupid video
games at the cord and [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] thing in the living room and
they would argue and then their friends
would come over
and i went over there one time and they
had stitches
they got robbed and they got beat up and
[ __ ] and they told me they didn't have a
gun like what type of drug dealers don't
have [ __ ] guns
so i went and got them a [ __ ] piece
how nice of you yeah and then we became
friends ever since
and i started going over there but you
were asking me their existence
how he still
is in business that was the conversation
we had this night and how like how he
could survive and not
go to jail like how he could survive and
make a living at this time right now i
talk to him once a month i know
i know what type of action he does i
know how he does it
and i don't how he moves he's got kids
and he's very careful okay
oh he's all dry careful
even years ago
very careful very careful all right he
controlled everything from a
to z
do you follow me
in his whole life or just
hit this this operation he had he would
pick up
at a certain place an hour away from
here
because he had dealt with these guys for
20 [ __ ] years
and he would get the specific brand of
powder
mexican dudes [ __ ] really good coke
and he would bring it back
to some chick's house in the valley and
he would chop it up
and i think he would put it in the safe
or something i don't know exactly but he
would take it
he would never take it to his house in
hollywood
he had another apartment in hollywood
where he had somewhere where he made pit
stops
he never really had the same car he
always had a bicycle or
but the beauty about these guys are that
lee didn't understand
was that his customer base is maybe 12
to 14
people he doesn't go outside that
customer base
he knows if something's up if somebody
comes to him with a weight
problem
you know what i mean
no i don't know what that means
so lee syed
is a comedian and he makes pretty good
money and he always cops an eight ball
from me when he comes back on sunday
nights
he may cop another one on tuesday
but if he's in town he cops on thursday
and friday and saturday some nights well
he's a good customer
what if lee calls me one night and he
goes hey
can i come over to the house i'm gonna
buy two ounces of coke
right there there's something going off
this guy never buys two ounces of coke
even though he's a good customer good
customer all of a sudden he hit the
jackpot
no i don't have it and you hang up the
[ __ ] phone
and you disconnect your page you lay low
for a few days you clean out your house
and you move on with your life for about
a month
just from that one phone call that's
crazy
that's
what a professional does
i never did it i wasn't a professional
but that's why he's been doing it for 16
years
you asked me what does he make a year
that night i told you probably makes a
quarter of a million dollars selling
nothing bigger than eight balls
he's got such a strong contingent
of hollywood producers
directors writers
that want very much uh what's that word
called
they don't want they want the
they just want the the coolness no no no
when i was in high school there was a
teacher i met mr mcgrath and the reason
why mr mcgrath was
the liberty coke was because it's better
than a spanish guy delivering coke to
the house
uh okay
in those days it wouldn't look good if a
colombian came up with lisa ayat's house
so they'd have this guy come over here
to look nice
my friend
that you know he looks nice you know
what i'm saying it's not like he looks
like some [ __ ] uh bumpy
he's always dressed to the nines
you know he's always got to cover he's
got he goes to acting class right
every week he books commercials from
time to time he's not a big time actor
but he's got that cover he also has
another [ __ ] cover
but i know what he sells every night
he's got to be pushing an ounce now
at night a night in in eight chunks
sometimes six chunks that seems like a
lot sometimes
four chunks sometimes you'll sell
four quarter ounces to four people boom
he got an ounce sold
he always shuts down at one
he used to shut down at 11.
if you call him at a minute after 11 his
phone's turned off
me and him were so tight that i was
allowed to go to his house
leave and then he'd meet me somewhere
do you know what i'm saying
why would you have to do that because i
would never leave with something in my
pocket and leave him in there
so he was that good with me so remember
i showed you last week
and holly we were at the light and i saw
that computer store right yeah and i go
that's why i used to meet dante that was
a 24-hour [ __ ] uh
internet cafe a cafe
and we could a computer cafe so people
go in there all night and get on their
computers he would sit in there all
night and be on the computer like a
[ __ ] nerd
and then you just go in there everybody
thought he was a computer nerd no he was
in that moving [ __ ] blow
see that seems like how people would be
like why is someone coming in here and
seeing him every night was he there
every night or would he change he would
sit there on the weekends
the owners knew him everybody knew him
nobody said a word to me bring coffee
bring donuts
and he'd sit in the back with earphones
on
he sit in the back with earphones on the
computer and then you came in hey what's
going on
he'd shake your hand the money was in
your hand and they put the money on the
computer you took the eight ball off the
[ __ ] computer
i give him credit
i give him [ __ ] credit
hey listen he beat this system he
figured out a way to beat the [ __ ]
system
but the issue i have
he put his kid through college uh-huh
he put his kids to a [ __ ] college
that's amazing
like nothing happened like they live
like a nice you know
like nobody knows nothing
the thing that doesn't that the why i
still don't think i don't understand how
it's possible still i i understand what
you said
it's like you you have these rules with
yourself like the
the uh the no texting whatever this and
we always talk about how how
dumb people are sometimes
i don't trust
i i think i would maybe trust you
if i was gonna sell coke to anyone like
if for some whatever reason i was a coke
dealer i think you would be the only
person in my life who i trust
i don't think i could trust anyone else
i can't find 12 people who i would trust
what if one night you get coked up and
you want coke and you don't care that
i'm closed at 11.
like if i like it's just no no but
remember you're gonna have a bartender
at the comedy store
you're gonna have a musician at the
whatever
okay you're gonna have yourself uh a
waitress
at the roxy you're gonna have uh
a maitre d and [ __ ] cafe leo
you're gonna have yourself these people
and you're gonna get to know them and
you know if you avoid the first five or
six years
you're good
you're pretty [ __ ] good unless you're
stupid you go out every night you drink
you have to blow on you it's in the
trunk of your car you got a scale in
your house
then you go into different realms the
problem with that [ __ ] where
he's succeeded is that he always sticks
to his rules
i don't think a lot of people do that
the why i don't think a lot of people do
that anymore well we had this
conversation you and i last week on the
phone
and it's called scheduling
and
the same problem i'm having right now in
my life
is where you have to be him
i've been thinking a lot about him and
how tight he runs his game
and how he takes vacations
he doesn't have stuff at his house you
know he has uh counter surveillance
stuff he has an attorney on call
i mean he's a one-man store
okay he doesn't have an assistant
he doesn't have 10 guys around them with
weapons and jumping up and down there is
nothing
if he walked in here right now you think
he worked with me in a movie
or you thought he was a fellow comedian
or whatever
he doesn't really eat drinks but in this
house
he gets [ __ ] up with his house he
doesn't do powder at all
does not do any powder at all did he
ever nope
nope never did powder whatsoever
how [ __ ] crazy is that that's the one
that always got me if that thing was in
my living room i was doing it jack
but
he doesn't do it that it's it's these
little rules
i don't have his home number
i have his main
phone but everything else
is throwaway phones
he calls you from throw away phones
he goes through six different numbers a
month
but i call him on his main cell phone on
his main cell phone there's no business
talked
no i gotta see you know
what time can you swing by no nothing
how you doing what's going on do you
have a spot tonight yeah i may come by
not really i'm out of town blah blah
blah i love you all right love you too
that's it
because he's worried about surveillance
right so he'll call me
he would call me or see me and go
this is the number i'm gonna be until
midnight at midnight the pumpkin [ __ ]
dies and at midnight that pumpkin died
jack
that when i first met him he would go
through phones once a week
new phone number
and he'd make one run or two runs
he'd always have uh
a woman with him
and like the only thing i know is no
fancy car
that doesn't even own the car how would
he get all the phones cause like in the
wire they had to send them down
he kind of deal with somebody
and i asked him what somebody bring some
hot phones or something 24-hour phones
brother
or you go to 7-eleven i guess or radio
shack i think it's 7-eleven right you
buy the 24-hour phones yeah you can do
that yeah those were [ __ ] little uh
alika bob phones whatever dude who blew
up the world trade center whatever his
name
so how would he would he he i don't
think he wrote your number down did he
no
and if he does i don't do blonde it's
got nothing to do with me no no that's
not what i meant like if he was changing
numbers all the time how would you get
into contact with them like how'd he
remember people's numbers he had them
all on his head no way
i'm gonna call you and say i'm gonna be
here for three days you got that money
you owe me
you know he caught you and said can i
see you and i'd meet him and i'd give
him the money at home and i'd take
something else from him and he'd
disappear for four more days
i'm in i'm in awe of him when we got
into that conversation i had just spoken
to him like three days
when i go to hollywood like when i go to
hollywood tuesday
i'll call him as i'm leaving the
doctor's office
because he's right around the corner
do you guys ever get together anymore
hang out
no i pull up in front of his house
i give him a big hug
he asked me how the baby's doing
i ask him how his kid is doing
he [ __ ] because the kid goes to
school out of state that's killing him
so we complain about that and that's
where it ends i tell them how much i
love them and i [ __ ] drive off into
the night
every once in a while
i'll call them
and then
like if you need ecstasy in vegas
i can get jacks to see in vegas
does he ever propose like hey man you
need anything
or no no
when i stopped doing coke i didn't call
him play two months
even though he called me and i didn't
call him play two months maybe three
months okay
and then one day he came to the store
and he knows what's going on
i think i owe them like 600 bucks i told
him to take a ride with me
and we went over to the [ __ ] uh
atm that game for the 400 i could take
out i said give me a few weeks i'll give
you the other two and he asked me what's
going on
that he had some new [ __ ] if i needed it
he could swing it by go no i'm done
and we talked and he goes i'm really
happy he goes one night you came over
and you kind of scared me and i remember
that i was [ __ ] up
you know what i didn't like leaving the
house when i did coke do you know what
i'm saying like i didn't like leaving
the house for me to leave the house
it has to be that i'm going crazy
why
because i'd be so paranoid and so [ __ ]
up towards the end
those last couple years
my friend died marilyn martinez
and but before marilyn died her husband
a year before maryland died or two years
her husband got addicted to [ __ ]
oxygen no
vikings
vikings
big time big time him bobby lee
all those guys were going to san diego
and [ __ ] but when he couldn't go to san
diego he was broke
he would call me up i had a friend in
houston that every time i went down
there he would give me a [ __ ] jar
of vikings i didn't eat vikings i had a
bad experience
so i would bring him back and give him
to him
and so what he would call you every time
he didn't have money and ask for those
buckets or whatever yeah
[ __ ] pills are scary
i didn't know the point of that story
was i'm so [ __ ] high that chocolate
from [ __ ] chibachu was
that's the second time last week i was
scared to drive home i couldn't stop my
711 [ __ ] rolling papers that night
i had to go home thank god i found the
rolling paper my [ __ ] uh
and my goddamn thing
oh
i just wanted to mention one thing from
what we were talking about earlier with
the working high
it's the one i really wanted to talk
about was how like
it went from the point of me being
scared
and me being
nervous about it and now
you're gonna know you you told me to
stop because now when i get high i get 8
000 terrible ideas and i call you up and
i start giving you ideas
so it's it's actually gotten to a place
where you can actually work it's
actually like a helpful work tool like
like maybe maybe
20 000 of them are terrible but if one
of them is good well the thing about
marijuana use is that when you started
for
depending on how hard you go at first
it's just uh you're getting over you're
in high you're getting over your eye for
a long time like you're like i can't
believe i'm [ __ ] out
and that's like the first two or three
or maybe four years right
and then one day you know i always did
pop like everybody else right but then
one day you realize wait a second
i could smoke this and interact with
people
and it becomes a complete different
[ __ ] game
i myself worked three times harder when
i smoked my own one that's me
because i'm used to it today i had to do
something i said let me take five
minutes go outside get my head together
and that's exactly what i did i came
back and i did 22 things at once
i put the videos up i wrote i emailed a
friend
that works for me you know i'm happy it
works for you i'm happy that you're
finally not scared anymore
you know you were scared because of what
your mom told you
yeah your friends told you what
everybody [ __ ] told you
it's tough [ __ ] living down man
i was thinking about it today
there's people who who listen to this
podcast and myself included
who are like mad at you
every day in our lives
because
like we'll be sitting
and listening to people talk about about
this and that
and you will just like you can see
through the [ __ ] in it because of
all the stuff we talk about
and it's like it ruins like for me like
it ruins like watching football all day
i used to love watching football all day
why can't i love watching football day
for my life and not know that i'm being
lazy piece of [ __ ] why can't i just sit
there and eat wings and pizza and get to
be 400 pounds
i went through the same [ __ ] thing
brother
no man listen
you
i love your pieces and you're learning a
very valuable education
and you're learning an education that i
never [ __ ] learned
because people mentioned it to me and i
saw people doing it but i thought there
were suckers
and i thought they didn't have their act
together or anything like that that was
completely wrong because all those
people today are very successful they
own things
and they work themselves into something
they're not millionaires not the forbes
top 20
millionaires they don't have boats they
don't they didn't want that
they just wanted comfort in their old
age
so they would want for nothing when they
were older and their two kids could get
educated or three kids it's very
expensive to put your kids through
college
it's getting worse and worse
and
the thing i learned the most
was work ethic
okay a couple months ago something
happened that was very shocking to me
and i could see in your face it was
wearing on you a little bit
okay
and
now you have to do this
you've been doing it all along
but now it seems like if you want to
start this podcast business you have a
lot of dreams and aspirations you have
to do this
paula was preparing for her
uh
gmac whatever the [ __ ] it's called bar
bar and paula knew
uh
the importance of this
she knew the importance of this bar and
what it meant to her and
she had loans on the line and blah blah
blah and uh
and paula basic basically for eight
weeks became a [ __ ] refuge
and i could see it was wearing on you a
couple weeks you're like me we're lonely
people we go home and after an hour like
should i jump out the window or
and you were calling me doing periscopes
eating stars people hitting me up going
joey's eating stars by himself
but we all learned the lesson
you know and uh
i never forget when she came back from
italy i said to you
is she ready
and you looked at you like i don't
really know paul is ready i don't know
if she knows that the vacation's over
becomes life but guess what she went up
the next day and got a [ __ ] job yeah
she got the first job she didn't read
first job
the first job she applied for no no no i
applied interval like like the real
first job she never interviewed for once
again yeah she got the first [ __ ] job
so
what i'm trying to tell you people is i
learned something from that
i learned that maybe paula failed i know
she's gonna pass because
the hours she put into it
normal people
can't understand that
the third day when i call ball and go
paula
i'm making chicken cutlets with reefers
stars
brad pitti and she's like i can't do it
cause i gotta study for my bar
he would call me and be like
what are you guys gonna do
and i'm like nothing i'm laughing or
she's studying it'll be like eight
o'clock and i need to be like studying
camera get over here
and i got it yeah
you get a different respect for people
because they stuck yeah
to their [ __ ] guns
something people don't do
and then they go one day oh i failed i
don't know why
the biggest lesson i want you to listen
from this late
is
timmy my friend timmy god bless him he's
a truck driver
he works five days a week
that's a job he took it's a great job
it's a union job he gets paid well he
gets benefits
that's a job timmy took
you took a job
that
you don't really know what
this job qualifies
nope this job is perfectly
you come in two days we smoke we tape it
i leave you cut it and put it up
and you can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want after that well guess what those
results were horrible yeah you gained
some weight you fell in love and
you almost got caught up in the house
you couldn't get out the one day you
said you couldn't get out you got all
that so much chinese food someone to
take out the sodium at you by the sides
and [ __ ]
and you realize you had to do something
else and you started making calls in the
morning
and when you're a freelance [ __ ]
there's
no days off
but there's no days off
and people don't understand that and
when you have to stick to that program
like there's always something to do what
we always talk about there's always
something to do don't tell me there's
something to do you know what get up
change the light bulbs put that one over
there and put that one over there
there's something to do
that zeppelin thing got dust on it
there's always something to do with a
[ __ ] job
i said to you take the other perspective
you were always talking about an ad
sales person right i said start making
calls how much success did you have
tremendous zero no you did great well
before
well no no you we had the [ __ ] reefer
with the pin
they didn't want to lift the rock you
had the [ __ ] wreath for people that
the with the with the the license and
the [ __ ] hey
oh yeah that's true yeah no no no no no
no you started getting the couple and
now you realize that you come in here on
sundays sometimes you get some [ __ ] done
and you come in and you know what this
has come now this is a six day a week
job for you oh yeah and guess what if
you open up this [ __ ] podcast
business sorry charlie
sorry charlie this is a seven day a week
job
and if there's a leak on friday night
and you're in the movies with paula
jumping up and down watching one of
those bad movies guess what you got to
show up at that [ __ ] leak
i know it's uh to be quite honest
i'm not like i'm not tired tired
but like it's
like we were talking about
did i think if paul was ready
this is more work
and it's just it's the the hour the
hours are weird it's
it's it's not that i don't enjoy it and
love it and
and i'm pushing through but this it's a
grind it's at certain points
like no well not not just the podcast
but then driving down to to meet to to
do
podcasts and on in pasadena or in
beverly hills or something like that
or or sending emails and it's it's
like you you just said earlier today
that you're busy you said you've been
busy for years so you're getting busier
like it just it's just getting
at a different point of being busy and
i'm
i'm like still getting used to it you're
learning all the possibilities that we
could do with the podcast right yeah so
right now you're exploring a lot of them
i don't have the time to explore a lot
of them
on the other situation
i'm just and i gotta tell you something
it's
it's i'm i'm just as busy as i am with
standup as being a dad i'm just as busy
with the podcast as being a dad
you know
in a way i don't have time for a social
log
life uh our friend uh feebles
the cuban kid right yeah that works in
burbank good friend of mine gave me a
great big band dike book
i'm gonna see if i get dick van dyke to
sign it before he punches the [ __ ]
ticket you know what i'm saying because
it's just the book is that great
but he's uh we were talking about foods
the other night you know dante gazzini
same [ __ ] thing he'll hit me up
and send me pictures of his cuban food
and torrents that
feebles was talking about listen you're
in no danger
unless we helicopter it down that's
three [ __ ] hours to torrance it's an
hour to torrance
and then now we're [ __ ] back from
torrance it's not gonna [ __ ] happen
never you know now why not joey i'll
tell you why not i don't have the
goddamn time
i wish i did
and if i go down and the bread is bad
i'm gonna throw the [ __ ] play that
your goddamn head so
forget about this whole [ __ ] thing
it's not gonna work out for you
you know it's it's amazing where the
time has gone
when i go home my friend georgie no you
don't want to eat a chance
you want to eat at this chinese place
yeah it's an hour away george i don't
have that [ __ ] convenience i gotta be
in new york city at seven [ __ ]
o'clock
that means you're gonna drop me off
around the [ __ ] uh ferry
so
respect your time man
if you're uh a nice schedule great guys
i'm a [ __ ] great schedule
i schedule [ __ ] you know i have a friend
shane
this is where i left you know mitch
hedberg
mitch hedberg was a great writer right
and a great performer you know why
because mitch shut his phone off from 8
to 12.
every day every [ __ ] day
that seems like a good thing to do
i shut my phone off in the morning when
i get back from mercy i turned that
[ __ ] off right after the
periscope that phone gets shut off
till one o'clock
the agent knows how to get a hold of me
that's it who needs to know who else
my wife knows how to get a hold of me
that's it
why i was wasting too much time for
years [ __ ] around because every time
you get involved in something the phone
rings
all the time all the [ __ ] time
and the phone rings eight times in a row
so nothing even starts is that when i
when i try to shut the phone off there's
one line on the [ __ ] page and i'm
sitting there going jesus christ what
happened to the [ __ ] hour and a half
i was sitting here at marie et how many
times i went to mariet sometimes i go to
mariet and i do great
sometimes i go to marie 18 i don't do
dick those are the times i bring the
phone to drink coffee with me
so i got a [ __ ] idea i ain't bringing
the [ __ ] coffee over there and i
ain't [ __ ] bringing the phone out of
the car no i put it in the trunk
with some ice on top but to cool it off
in the bag i swear to god you didn't
know that
no you put it really so it doesn't
overheat yeah it doesn't overheat
because it gets really hot in that
[ __ ] parking lot let me do some shout
outs
and we'll get the [ __ ] out of here lisa
yeah
interesting [ __ ] tonight no i i couldn't
believe how
pissed off
people got at me about the cm punk thing
and
all i saw guys was his balls i want to
apologize for my man sabatino
not calling in tonight somewhere along
the line he got stick of shock i got to
be honest with you guys um
this is the fourth time
i've tried to get somebody from that
area to call in
and they won't call it
and then didn't we have someone who
carlos perez yeah
i think another friend of mine i want to
say his name
and a girl
that that area down there where i grew
up when my mother died given that
terrorist down there 38th street
charles court
all those kids have a certain uh
it was weird i took lee up then i go
leap put the camera down
and right when we got to charles court
some guy said put that [ __ ] camera
and i was like lee i told you
these three blocks here were programmed
anti-camera
anti-fucking camera but i'm really
surprised that car might let them tape
us
tapes
documentary
it's really surprising to me especially
with that area especially when he taught
us and how he worked
i uh i don't know i text sabatino uh you
text him and uh
nothing happened so i don't know what
happened so i'm sorry the viewers this
would have been a really good interview
we spoke twice today
uh we spoke about what we're going to
talk about the state of mind and what i
got from down there
growing up down there i think a lot of
my [ __ ] is from down there
it really is
because there was a lot of old-timers
down there lived on those side streets
and we would always talk to them
and they would express their views and i
would laugh my [ __ ] ass off there was
one guy latino that was the most racist
guy in the [ __ ] world
right in front of me so i didn't mind
and they were like homeless no he had he
owned one of the houses he was the
italian guy his wife was selling the
buckling and just watch people going up
and down the block and then tell people
about everybody's gossip
jesus christ but when he'd see me go
look at look at the science over there
[ __ ] hebes
look i'm
bringing in [ __ ] bagel unlocks you
think they come over here and invite me
for bagel unlocks [ __ ] though because
i'm a catholic they don't want me
look at the other people at the block
the altmans look at them
i used to love living in the north end
in boston because like they would bring
like like i literally
had neighbors who would bring their like
living room ottomans
like big rocking chair things down to
the street and just sit there shirtless
all day talking talking that's it but
they're watching
and he would just sit there with his
[ __ ] white wife
and just watch and complain and then as
i was walking up the street with the
basketball he would unload on me like
you're spanish
you're never going to be a professional
basketball player you got a better
chance of being a [ __ ] waiter
you and the rest of those speakers in
there and i wouldn't get mad at him i
would giggle and call him a guinea [ __ ]
and that was the end of that
pickaroo let me do some shout outs my
condolences
to uh jason monteiro
his wife my heart goes out to your
family dole chandler
jason [ __ ]
lloyd charles sample
stelio contrast el parco junior meg
and lizily love
i also want to talk about this uh
i'm trying to get lee one of these they
sent me uh because the person said yeah
we're gonna give you two [ __ ] beds
and they go no you gotta do one for 30
days and give us your sample and then so
i don't know how this [ __ ] thing
works i recently moved
and one of our sponsors uh
i read great things about their product
and i offered to do like a sample run or
whatever and they sent me
a mattress
and
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened
it came in the box lee
and i looked at this thing i'm like
we're getting [ __ ] beat this is too
small
and this turned out to be one of the
best mattresses i ever had as soon as i
go to my wife's side i can feel the
difference my wife got the cold bed
which stays cool you know a couple days
ago i went on their website and i
watched what you needed to do to get a
bed from them and it really is
unbelievable how far we've gone in
technology now for a bed for three
thousand [ __ ] years everybody slept
on a cover with little skinny pines and
vines under it and [ __ ] it's a complete
different situation
you know you're unique you don't walk
like everybody else you don't talk like
everyone you don't sleep like anyone so
why is your mattress one size fits all
i just just i listen i didn't know about
this for years but i gotta tell you
something
when helix sleep
all that stuff goes away because it's a
custom mattress and you thought it was
gonna cost you five to ten thousand
bucks right not until now what i'm gonna
bring you is helix sleep where you can
buy mattresses online
customized for hundreds of dollars
instead of thousands what you do is you
go to helixsleep.com
and you answer some simple questions
based on four key preferences your
weight your height you know john what
side of the bed does your wife sleep
what side of the bed you sleep on stuff
like that they'll do a custom sleep
profile they'll build you the most
comfortable mattress you'll ever sleep
on your mattress will arrive at your
door in about a week all right and
shipping is 100 free
for couples helix customizes each side
of the mattress one for my wife one for
me
helix customers report 30 improvement in
overall sweep sleep quality you have 100
nights to try it out and if you don't
love it all right love it like me
they'll pick it up for free and give you
100 refund no questions asked that's why
everyone from gq magazine to forbes
they're all talking about healing sleep
so do me a favor you know i don't blow
smoke up your ass it's a great deal it's
a phenomenal mattress you can customize
let's say your kid wants to sleep in the
middle they get dick they get the
[ __ ] middle that's the way it's been
more for 2 000 years it's a great bet
it's comfortable you know what it's
cheap and affordable do me a favor go to
helixsleep.com
joey again
helixsleep.com joey and get fifty
dollars off your order that's
helixsleep.com
joey
helixsleep.com joey 30 improvement in
overall sleep and i'm gonna give you 50
off your order not to mention you got
100 nights to try it out and if you
don't love it
we'll pick it up 100
refund all right no questions asked
again just go to helixsleep.com and take
a peek you're going to love it if you
like something go to helixleep.com joey
and get 50 50
off your first order how's that one for
you also i want to salute my people on
it they have a thing these mixed greens
i've heard about that guys go on there
right now and try it
i've been farting good i've been going
in the bathroom good my stomach feels
better my skin feels better except for
this [ __ ] zit on my nose everything's
[ __ ] beautiful and you know what from
the shroom tech sport to the shroom tech
mune i'm out of the protein shake again
i gotta water more i ain't gonna blow
smoke up your ass i use this stuff guys
and it works tremendously do me a favor
go to honor.com right now slash joey no
no church slash church
and look at their website look at the
minerals look at the vitamins see if
anything works out for you and it suits
your lifestyle whether you're a hiker a
jiu jitsu guy a weight lifter a
kettlebell lifter whatever the [ __ ] you
do and it has something to eat for you
to optimize your workout and your life
on a real level do me a favor go to
audit.com right now if there's something
you like
go to the box when you're checking out
and press in church i get 10 percent off
and it gets delivered right to your door
again i'd like to thank
helix sleep and i'd like to thank
honett.com
for uh supporting the podcast
i had to thank you guys for listening
sorry that the [ __ ] pooped out on you
[ __ ] but wednesday we got a
great guest and guess what thursday me
and lee austin [ __ ] texas
at the cap city comedy club go there
tonight because tickets are going fast i
don't know what it is about this time of
the year tickets move these clubs are
small number two the following week i'm
at gotham in new york city again i hear
the the first show's already sold out so
oh [ __ ] that's what i heard from my
buddy of mine called me from new york he
wants a table of me
so there you go people i'm trying to
bail you out uh i'll see you
[ __ ] wednesday night thank you
for supporting us thank you for the love
i'm giving you my [ __ ] heart and what
i feel all right [ __ ] i want to
thank lisayet my number one [ __ ]
doom [ __ ] number one i love the duck
thank you buddy i love you and i can't
wait to see everybody in austin
everybody always asks let's do this [ __ ]
do this
oh [ __ ] god
what's up
foreign
so
and nothing else
so
so
we like it
thank you
you